si jamais elle avait rien fait vous
auriez dit regardez elle est là elle
fait rien et tout ça là il se bouge elle
y va elle
venait d'avant ça c'est poursuivi après
il y avait un vrai problème elle
intervient honnêtement je dis là elle a
fait prendre le courage voilà c'est les
hommes ils bougent plus c'est elle a
bougé les autres ils ont bougé
personne bouge personne
on va avoir un drame je vous dis et ça
va ça va mal se terminer je le sais tu
as mal terminé on le sait tous hein
voilà c'est cohabiter au mieux non mais
voilà toi voilà ton cohabiter au mieux
arrête de faire n'importe quoi
demain si vous voulez demain je vous
fais une vidéo
demain je me fais insulter mais tous les
matchs mais tous les livreurs qui me
regardent bien sûr
mais les gens les gens quand tu quand tu
te gares et tu peux pas te garer jusqu'à
Paris avec un cycliste mais je me suis
embrouillé avec un cycliste j'ai fait
que ça moi des embrouilles bah les mecs
qui tapent sur ton rétro il ton rétro il
croit que tu vas partir mais moi je
descends du camion je vais le voir j'y
vais remettre le rétro je te laisse pas
partir voir en mettre le rétro c'est des
embrouilles à deux balles parce que ça
se trouve il y a 3 cyclistes ils vont
venir ils vont marcher je me retrouve au
sol et c'est moi qui vais me faire
déverrouiller mais tous les jours il y a
des embrouilles comme ça tous les jours
il y a des envies d'en parler et pensons
aussi tous les jours piétons parce que
si j'avais autant de mecs que doit
donner de cyclistes je serai je serai
trop
lentement
[Rires]
on parle toujours vélo contre voiture je
suis désolé moi je suis que piétonne
quasiment et je m'embrouille tous les
jours avec des avec des cyclistes j'ai
froid je peux écrire un livre il
m'insulte il me font des doigts
d'honneur juste parce qu'ils sont sur le
trottoir c'est pas ils y sont pas à leur
place et simplement je l'ai je me
permets de les engueuler bah doit
d'honneur sale grosse tu ferais mieux
d'en faire du vélo mais j'entends ça
tout le temps la prochaine fois tu
m'appelles ah ben je peux je peux vous
dire que c'est vrai et il y a un royaume
il y a un mec qui m'a dit ça ils étaient
deux avec sa femme ils sont arrêtés un
peu plus loin sa femme je les ai
rejoints et j'ai suivi je l'ai suivi à
pied dans tout Royan en disant vous
voyez ce monsieur là il m'a traité de
sale grosse j'ai fait ça pendant tout au
tour ailleurs et la dame disait tu vois
je t'avais dit de pas dire ça un autre
truc
la prochaine fois tu m'appelles
franchement voilà c'est c'est ça tout le
temps la vie d'un piéton je suis désolé
même au téléphone je vais tellement les
insulter
d'accord tu fais une journée avec
n'importe qui pas moi n'importe quel un
taxi un livreur quelqu'un qui roule
toute la journée dans Paris toi tu fais
une journée à 8h du matin à 9h tu
descends de la voiture parce que tu vas
tuer quelqu'un non je te jure que j'ai
fait surtout pour l'odeur